actually it's become a good business for
our clients good business for us because
it's good business with our clients and
because it's good business with our
people it's a way of differentiating wpp
in its constituent parts from the
competition we know from all the data we
get from companies like millward brown
and research international and TNS our
research companies that consumers admire
and respect companies that invest in
these areas that respect these areas and
we also know that people coming out of
universities or art schools or design
schools or thinking about switching from
one company to another in our industry
or joining the industry or even thinking
about doing other things within our own
company they're held and attracted by
commitment to these areas so that's a
it's not about doing good or altruism
all this and that's a very good side
effect it's about good long-term
business if you're in business for the
long term this is something that you
should do because it's good business
well I think I think business has no
choice in that sense I think the
pressures are so great you know I mean
just take health for example we know we
know I think that babies that are born
today in Europe might be the same evenly
in the United States to have a 50-50
shot at getting to a hundred years old
so if the you know average length of
life was 75 80 85 years a few years ago
or 60 65 years ago it's now verging
towards a century if not at a sentry to
live longer you're going to have to live
a healthier life you're going to have to
consume healthier foods so if you just
take the food area for example I think
companies that embrace this area a will
be more successful economically so it's
another you know business argument be
they will be more attractive to
consumers we know that already from the
research evidence that I've referred to
before and see we'll be more attractive
destinations for for talent and the war
for talent is going to be so so
difficult because of some of these
things that we're talking about I mean
there are birth rates of falling the
ages of populations even in relatively
young countries like a Mexico I mean
Mexico I think starts to peak in terms
of its age profile under i think around
2018 2019 2023 sure in a sense at that
point in time the supply of talent given
birth rates are falling giving divorce
rates rising given people getting
married later having fewer children rise
of women in the workforce all of those
things are going to reduce the supply of
talent that's where the shortage is
going to be for companies like it not
just like our own which are in
professional services but you know if
you're running an oil refinery there
will be a shortage of people to even run
even on that so the war for talent would
come increasing importance so this is
just good business again from a people
point of view if you if you
race these areas which I think from a
consumer point of view unnecessary from
a social point of view unnecessary from
an environmental point of view necessary
but NGOs applaud that governments
applaud if you embrace those areas the
people that are either inside your
company or could potentially become
inside your company will applaud too so
I think this it all fits neatly together
in the context of what's of what's
happening the big question is is whether
we're going to move rapidly enough
whether people are going to be have
taken this seriously enough whether
they're prepared to engage because it's
a bit like the threat of the the the
internet or the opportunity of the
internet you know if you run a legacy
company in them in the media area if
your meter owner or running an agency
and advertising agency or indeed a
client and they've been used to to
traditional media and along come the new
media which have a totally different
profit model totally different operating
model and you have to run a legacy
business at the same time you are trying
to embrace these new areas well the same
thing is true about sustainability
sustainability means you probably have
to run your business in a very different
way and what was profitable before you
know if you're in the car business for
example if you've got factories and
people who are committed to building
cars and trucks in a certain way and you
have to alter the way you do it you have
to build new factories you have to
design new products new models takes
time to do that anywhere up to three
four five you just take five years
probably now takes them about three
years so there's a there's a process but
you've also got these legacy factors
which are committed to working in the
the old way which makes it increasingly
makes it very difficult so it's it's the
white sheet of paper companies as I call
them so in the in the media area those
companies that start without newspaper
factories or plants that fell trees and
distribute newsprint they have an
advantage similarly in the
sustainability area if you're if you're
starting from scratch you're funded by
venture capital or private equity you've
got a remarkable advantage over somebody
who's running a legacy company who has
to worry about dealing with the legacy
issues and plants already established I
think one of the really good things is
that if you look at what's happening in
the Silicon Valley if you talk to the
venture capitalists and private equity
people on the west coast of America they
are amazed that the extent of the
commitment of new capital and you are
backing new ideas in the in the area in
the green areas and sustainability